i saw these two best friends in bikinis
do a yoga challenge so i went and got
bikinis and asked my best friend to try
it with me
all aboard
selena gomez is a multi-talented singer
dancer actress and entrepreneur thank
you but when it comes to recreating yoga
tick-tock trends yeah maybe not her
strong suit
on monday the 29 year old singer posted
this video to tick tock hanging out with
a pal and attempting to recreate this
video by comedian robin shaw
i saw these two best friends in bikinis
do a yoga challenge so i went and got
bikinis and asked my best friend to try
it with me
as you can see selena's yoga challenge
went just about as well as robin's my
god i love it but we're going to give
them both 10 out of 10 for effort and
delivering huge laughs
all aboard
i am so excited tic toc seems to be
selena's happy place lately she's posted
many videos showing off her dance moves
her fitness routine
but her tick tock of choice the lip sync
why do bad things happen to sexy people
miami here i come cause i'm not nobody's
baby mama so you're telling me that you
can read his astrological birth chart
but you can't read the red flags
sis selena's eight-year-old sister
gracie also gets in on the fun they've
appeared in several vids together
[Music]
and last week selena even let her pals
in the band girl pool film her while
getting a new piercing babe got
something right here your ear got belly
button oh my goodness and speaking of
tick-tock and trends it seems selena is
the one keeping those around her young
and hip i was so much fun not only did
she teach her only murders in the
building co-stars steve martin and
martin short about some very important
21st century lingo steve
are you an og i'm gonna switch i am such
an og
no you don't hit the g like that oh it's
not g-e-e oh yeah
oh gee
last month she revealed to et that she
educated her co-stars on the meaning
behind cardi and meg the stallion's song
[ __ ] which is about you know
i'm talking
that's some wet and gushy macaroni in a
pot that's some wet and cushy wait
selena did you explain [ __ ] to them
i certainly why can't you say w.a.p
because that's not what they say that's
not what the kids that's like calling
the usa usa
thank you for this service selena for
explaining and did you what did you guys
think when you learned the meaning of
wap well i you know i i i've known it
for years